the clinical practice as i experienced
it you know the workflow the patients
the the medicines we have the
diagnostics we have
are actually decades behind what
technology can actually offer us
and what science can actually offer us
welcome to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and
in media partnership with ctec welcome
to another episode of 20 minute leaders
i'm
joined today by khfiroved founder and
ceo of canopy
immunotherapeutics fear is a dual
background in medicine and a phd in
immunology
he is a serial bioentrepreneur with an
endless passion for outcome driven
personalized technology agnostic
medicine co-founder cto chairman of
medex dx
that translates our immune response
signals into accurate and actionable
diagnostics at the point of care
seated and serves as chief strategy in
navina ai
and recently founded and serves as the
ceo of canopy
immuno therapeutics field welcome to
20-minute leaders thank you for joining
me
minutes before you're taking a flight to
italy for your daughter's
carting competition thank you for
joining me how are you
i'm wonderful great to be here
so we're going to talk a lot about
biotech and medicine and
and you and your your time you know as
chief technology officer but but before
that i have to i have to stop and
dwell on on the fact that your three
children seem to all be
you know really into cars and carts
i believe you that that your daughter is
currently
racing and with the hopes of becoming
formula one driver and your son is a
looking as a mechanic
what's happening over there
so it's basically um we're pretty um
you know motorist sports fan a family so
um my daughter started with racing my
younger one
also followed her and the middle one is
actually a you know
a future to be engineer i think
so he was actually attracted not to the
driving
you know and to the stages but actually
to the
hard i would say you know tedious work
of being a mechanic but that's his
passion so
i mean they're all doing what they like
and i'm just here to support you know
and so was there anything specific that
that draws them into this
uh because it's it's it looks like the
three siblings are together
looking at something that is pretty
different from
you know the what you've been you know
dedicating yourself to
over these past years so let's just say
that daddy is is
is is a fan of sports cars okay and and
we'll put it there because again i don't
want to take too much responsibility on
that
i i love it so tell me a little bit
about your entrance to
the the biotech space so over you've
spent a lot of time being the cto
and chairman of mehmed dx translating
the immune response signals into
actionable diagnostics and point of care
i don't even know what what that
sentence means yet i'm gonna need you to
explain that to me
yeah but but how do you how do you
decide
that you're gonna work in in biotech
how does that happen so first of all a
lot of this a lot of decisions
in life are not being made by you but
actually by life itself and serendipity
um for me you know the big dream was to
be
a medical doctor and but my grades you
know my gpa grades in here in israel
were more in the order of three
something and not close to four as is
required here in israel
and actually actually you need some you
know really crazy grades
uh to get into med school and i had two
alternatives basically the first one was
to try to improve my gpa and the second
one was to
pursue a first degree in life science
and i decided to pursue a first degree
in life science in biology
in the technion institute of technology
which is the equivalent of faith you
know
united states mit and um i actually
started
with again with the aspiration just to
get into med school
no more no less but again just by
serendipity i just fell in love with
biology
and after graduating a biology first
degree with excellence and being
accepted to med school
i was offered very generously offered by
my one of my teachers in the faculty of
biology to actually
do a direct phd in biology and
this started actually seven
you know the hardest most exciting years
of my life
of you know taking med school in the
morning you know going to classes
being in the departments learning you
know the medical practice
and afternoon packing my things going up
the hill
to the camellia a faculty of biology and
starting putting the experiments in my
phd in immunology and
i think these were shaping years for me
because what i realized is that
um the clinical practice as i
experienced it
you know the workflow the patients the
the medicines we have
the diagnostics we have are actually
decades
behind what technology can actually
offer us and what science can actually
offer us
and for me for from here on and you know
this is reality and it will always be
the reality
so for me the crusade is becoming to
closing the gap
between you know big clinical problems
and you know science and technology i
come
from the clinical need and not from the
technology itself i think technology
needs to serve
the clinical need and not vice versa but
you know after graduating you know
both say my phd and you know finishing
the minister of health
exams i actually had three options the
first one is to go to the academy
um try to get a pi a position here in
israel
the second one was to become a
practicing physician
and the third one was something else and
you know what
something else happened so um i bumped
pretty
pretty close to graduating my med school
um into a
problem of antimicrobial resistance
bacterial
antimicrobial resistance which is um
actually a phenomena that we know since
the invention of antibiotics and
and and the basic phenomena is that once
you're using too much antibiotics
some bacteria are becoming resistant to
it and
under this selective pressure are also
controlling the environment
and this is by far one of the biggest
challenges in modern medicine it's not
about
pneumonia it's not about you know curing
the ear infection of your kid even
though it's also this but
it's actually about the entire future of
modern medicine because we don't have
oncology
without antibiotics and we don't have
neonatology
orthopedics without antibiotics if you
think about it that's
probably the very basic mainstay of
modern medicine as we know it
so losing the effectiveness of
antibiotics is
not a tiny thing it's actually a massive
massive
health care related problem and
you know i was doing my phd in
immunology these days and you know once
you have a hammer in your hand
everything looks like a nail right and
for me it was
it was like a perfect nail because
i actually said you know most of the
antibiotics is being over prescribed
because
people are mixing physicians are mixing
or cannot actually get into certainty
about whether a disease is viral or
bacterial where in bacterial you need to
prescribe antibiotics in viral
infections you do not
need you're actually not not recommended
to prescribe antibiotics at all
and i said you know basically this is
exactly what the immune system is doing
right the immune system is
identifying the pathogen identifying the
bug
if it's a virus it's mounting one attack
if it's a bacteria it's mounting a
completely different attack
okay so imagine we could actually
measure
our immune response and translate that
within minutes
into bacterial viral prescribe or do not
prescribe antibiotics
and this for itself might spare hundreds
of millions of over prescriptions of
antibiotics annually
just solving this seemingly tiny problem
okay um and that was basically the
beginning of the journey
so i decided not academy and not
practicing medicine
i decided to pursue after this after
this this specific problem with
um with my co-founder um and actually a
found meme diagnostics which is right
now um
a company that has over 100 employees
and raised over 100
20 million dollars and actually um
getting
very very close to the patients with
both the technology and a platform that
we developed
which again i'll be happy to to talk
about in the last decade
so that's um mimid um but
i think as i told you the journey didn't
stop for me in me
because for me um against once the once
the r
d and technology risk and went down it
was pretty obvious that you know
i would like to do many more things in
my life
and as part of that i helped to see
a pretty amazing digital health company
here
founded by a200 veterans
here in israel called navina a shine on
in
and also founded an immunotherapy
company that right now developed what we
call an anti-vaccine
which is a new class of molecules that
are doing exactly the opposite to what a
vaccine is doing
and by doing so might allow us to
to create either long-term remission or
even cure for patients with autoimmunity
and allergy
so um it's a long journey i hope it's um
you know
still on its way and um that's basically
how it all started so i have a
i have more of a personal question for
you how does it
i mean i'm just assuming but i think
it's a pretty safe assumption that most
people around you
and not necessarily in the offices but
most people around you in your life
don't necessarily understand
the details and the intricacies of what
you're doing uh
you know even if you sit down and i'm
and after these 20 minutes i'll i'll
begin to
gain the curiosity and and and the
passion to go and dive deeper
it's it's not trivial what you're doing
and and it's a lot of
it's a lot of things that require domain
expertise to even understand why what
you're doing makes sense and and how
it's actually going to impact and make
the the snowball effect later on
is that is that a challenge for you in
any way over the past
12 years or so with a memodex or or even
previously as you were studying these
things
of course and um i i think you know
maybe some entrepreneurs do not
experience it this way but
at least for me i mean it's an excellent
question i i've never been
asked this question before to be honest
with you and
the more i think about it and i think
it's a very important one because many
people come with
great ideas and um they have a very deep
conviction
of you know the value that they might
bring to the world
but they also need to bear in mind that
in many cases the immediate reaction and
even late reactions might not be
supportive might not fully understand
the potential of what they're suggesting
and in many cases might even be
considered ridiculous right or or you
know
or impractical and to be honest with you
you know
there are professors here in israel and
you know various respected professors
from medicine that they claim that you
know
you know what we suggested to performing
meme is is not going to be done
next 100 years we don't have the
technology to do that and that that's
never going to work so we heard you know
um
these type of uh you know i would say
you know
kind of dismiss you know of you know or
or tuning down
or you know lowering expectations from
what people believe you might
you might bring to the world and so this
is maybe one thing that
you know young entrepreneurs need to
take in mind or bear in mind that
it's not necessarily always going to be
um
you know a popularity context about what
you'd like to do the second thing is
that
professionally it's a very i think
it's very it's a very lonely life style
so
as you said i mean at home
yes you know you don't you cannot really
share anything because
you know it's it's just i mean you can
give the high level you can try to
describe it to others but
the real dilemmas are so complicated in
many cases so detailed and so
you know technical that you know who
cares i mean no one cares and know how
to understand the
the subtleties so you need you know to
actually uh have a dialogue with
yourself which is kind of
uh you know kind of uh psychiatric and
it's
you know in some aspects in shower you
know before you go to sleep
you know when you wake up in the middle
of the night
and you know you leave the bed and go to
the computer and
and think and work but um there aren't a
lot of people you can share your ideas
with that can fully understand and that
is not something
that you should take you know you know
either as an impediment
or as a proof that you're not right but
actually just the fact of life that
um it is going to be lonely
right and so what do you do in those you
know
12 or more years as you go through i
mean obviously you have that internal
conviction
that you know what you're doing is going
to make tremendous impact on the world
and it's going to make a tremendous
impact on a lot of people and i'm
and i'm sure that what you said before
that i'm sure that every time somebody
took a crack at what we're doing in
mehmed i i'm pretty sure that
you know it just spiked even more
interest than you to actually go and
prove
and prove them wrong but then how do you
then you know
what do you do in those 12 years to
actually push yourself forward
and make sure you're with the right
people and you're and you're really
getting that
the right atmosphere to be a good
entrepreneur
i think it's composed of two
maybe conflicting you know um i would
say
state of minds okay a state of mind
that the first one would be actually to
dream
okay to to be able to see a future a
different
future again as i said it all comes for
me at least from
a problem from a clinical dilemma and
you know other entrepreneurs in other
sectors completely different than
medicine and
and life sciences you know can also
apply the exact same
you know modus around your way of
thinking which is
what is the problem or what what is the
delta value that can be created here
and you need you need to be kind of a
dreamer but you need to be
on the other hand a practical dreamer so
on one hand you need to have a very
i think solid grand vision
to you know to a future that will look
differently
significantly better significantly
better right you know you know the 10x
a you know mantra from from peter thiel
and on the other hand um you need to be
extremely practical
so the goals and the steps and the plan
needs to be well thought through well
planned
very practical tied to a timeline tied
to a budget
tied to risk management etc and you know
it's always this
balance between being practical
being methodological being you know a
you know hard-working
to being what i call you know
you know dreamer or creative dreamer um
which is which is actually um
kind of disconnected from from the
current reality
of course i think i think that's the
point in fear so
the dreamer in you where you know
you're you've done so much of the hard
work and you know both with academia and
then all the all those years in mehmed
and now canopy
tell me tell me your dream where where
are we headed or where are we headed you
know the next
10 20 years and and how is the world
you know in your mind going to
re-experience
medicine and research through the work
that you're
spending most of your time today
i think medicine is not
going to be even two percent similar to
what it is today
in uh 50 years time um i think
what's going to change everything is
going to change everything is going to
change
so dramatically that i think people are
really
um not even close to understanding that
again the
the revolutions that were heading i
think the first
you know it has a few verticals the
first one is is gene editing
and you know the ability to manipulate
genes and to actually
play with our you know operating system
to tune it
to fix it to improve it and you know as
a you know the beginning would be to
cure diseases
but unfortunately i don't think it's
going to stop there we're going to
improve as species
um i hope that humanity is going to do
that properly with the right tape i
would say
ethical ethical you know rules but um
that's that's a threat that's something
that i'm actually pretty much concerned
about
the second element is of course deep
learning and artificial intelligence and
other you know machine intelligence
technologies that will for sure be
developed which are
slowly and surely and and recently also
pretty quickly and surely um we're
replaced physicians
so the role of the human being in
the clinical practice is going to change
from
the you know from the brains to the
patient you know to the human human
interaction and i think humans
in this respect if they will know how to
take these revolutions to their
advantage we'll get to the right place
that human beings should be
which is to support which is you know to
be
um you know empathetic which is to
um again to be more on the um i think um
mental side to the side of the patient
than
on the you know just being able to
diagnose properly
and suggest the right treatment because
i believe that 20 years from now
again algorithms are going to rule many
of these
processes both the diagnosis and the
the treatments so this is maybe a second
second element gene therapy one
artificial intelligence to
and on top of that you know you can
dream from here on about robotics what
robotics can do
you can dream about you know what other
deep technologies can
can do the medicine in any case you know
forget about i have you know
shortness of breath i'll schedule a
meeting with my md
three days from now you know go to the
clinic being examined for eight minutes
um get a piece of paper and usually
won't
won't get better so i don't see medicine
continue this way it's just um
it's it's just a non-sustainable and b
the amounts of data
that we're collecting today will bring
new notions new understanding medicine
is going to be computerized
completely um within within a few
decades
uh you know clear i'm leaving this call
with with so much energy even though
it's so early in the morning and
again thank you for taking the time
right before you're taking your your
daughter to
a carding competition in italy and i
think that
you know when you're describing this
idea of passion resilience and
and you know at the end a lot of being
very
you know honest with yourself and and
what you want to do and how to
also tackle the challenges around you i
i think it shines also through
through your the fun fact that he shared
with me and i really wanna um
you know thank you for coming for these
20 minutes it was really really
fantastic and
to me just it just you know creates the
curiosity to go and dive in deeper which
is exactly why i started this show and
so i really really thank you for that i
do have a few fun questions about you
before we leave and we'll start off with
a pretty easy one
but a really interesting one one of your
favorite subjects
from middle school or high school
unfortunately there is no such topic
so i hated high school and i was a lousy
lousy student i'm sorry to say that wow
um but i do want to say
all those lousy students in high school
today
that are dreamers that have a passion in
them
that oh high school is just high school
okay
you you can you can you can fly very
high
even if you're not an amazing student
with high school you can get really
great
student and you're passionate about what
you learn and what you do
i love it and who would be a role model
or
somebody that inspires you in this world
yeah
i i give it some thinking but you know
and i'm sorry to be a cliche
here and and i am a cliche in this
respect but
i'm a pretty consistent cliche for many
many years so
i'm a big big fan of elon musk and
and actually the reason why i i see elon
musk as
as a role model is not only because of
the vision of the guy
which disrupted you know traditional
industries one
after the other um but also and maybe
even more because
of the level of you know craziness
and dedication and you know and
and you know they
endless passion to what this guy is
doing so he had you know he spent
his 200 million dollars from his first
day
exit getting into near bankruptcy
and just to make that into 200 billion
dollars right but that's that's the end
of the story he didn't know when he
slept on the couches of
friends and family's
apartments he didn't know that he
invested everything he had
in what he believed and his level of
passion is
something i think is is you know
contagious is amazing
contagious i love that and what are
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
so the first word is actually um is two
words it's practical dreamer
i think it's really really important
because i'm not practical and i'm not a
dreamer
i'm a practical dreamer so that's point
number one
i'm extremely passionate about
everything i do
and passion is in everything i'm i'm
doing and i'm also a pretty sensitive
guy i think
so um that's maybe the third character
that that describes me
thank you very much very much this was
this was just
inspiring and and i this is the the
absolute best way to start off the day
thank you very very much have a safe
flight today
to your dog thank you very much